sanaa région nous allons parler du g7
mais d'abord un mot vous avez déclaré
hier que vous aviez vous en avez assez
de la fable du méchant flic et du gentil
casseurs alors que vous étiez en
déplacement à avignon et des violences
ce week-end en marge des déplacements
des gilet jaune le 20 mars il y avait
cent soixante-quatorze enquête de l'igpn
en cours quel est le chiffre aujourd'hui
concernant d'éventuelles violences
policières
199 pour l'igpn la police nationale 10
pour la gendarmerie nationale à travers
10 g gm attention ce sont des enquêtes
qui ne porte pas sur des violences
policières qui porte sur des faits qui
vont de l'insultent qui peut avoir été
évoqué jusqu'à des blessés et des
blessés qui peuvent être graves
où en sont ces enquêtes elles se
poursuivent elles seront placées sous
l'autorité judiciaire elles sont
détachés du ministère de l'intérieur
elles sont placées sous l'autorité d'un
procureur même si c'est l'inspection
générale de la police nationale la
gendarmerie nationale et elles se
poursuivent elles font l'objet du temps
nécessaire à des enquêtes et s'il ya des
fautes et table il y aura des sanctions
qu'il y en a eu
est ce qu'il y a d'ores et déjà eu des
sanctions non parce qu'il n'y a eu aucun
aboutissement de ces enquêtes
judiciaires actes parce que vous prenez
votre temps c'est pas moi je vous ai
indiqué dans la réponse précédente
elles sont placées sous l'autorité d'un
magistrat et donc c'est le temps de
blanquette le temps de l'enquète
implique justement surtout quand on met
en cause la responsabilité d'un homme ou
d'une femme que l'on prenne le temps de
cela mais ce que je veux ou préciser
c'est que on a eu plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de manifestations qui ont été
organisées et je vous parle de 199 cas
c'est cela la réalité par contre je vous
parlais aussi des 1628 policiers
gendarmes et pompiers qui ont été
attaqués ou qui ont été blessées dont
peut-être on ne parle pas assez aussi
tous les samedis de la violence jeté
hier à avignon
j'ai vu le stock d'armes qui a été saisi
je parle bien d'un acheteur que je parle
bien d'armes à la fois le pistolet des
machettes des battes de baseball des
gens qui viennent pour casser mais aussi
pour blesser nos forces de l'ordre sur
le cas du manifestant qui a reçu un coup
de matraque sur la tête à besançon vous
avez expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
violence possible de violence policière
ces images là naturellement les français
qui nous regardent ce matin les ont vues
elles peuvent être choquantes quelle est
la définition que vous donnez vous
christophe castaner d'une violence
policière des violences policières à une
violence policière c'est un acte
intentionnel
blessé quelqu'un alors que yann enquête
donc je vais pas me prononcer sur le
sujet mais je réponde à la question
d'une journaliste qui affirmait qu est
ce que vous pensez de cette violence
policière tu dis non si dans le cadre
d'une manifestation faisait ce qu'on
appelle un beau offensive de nos forces
de l'ordre pour dégager laon l'espèce
les faits qui sont évoqués ce sont des
manifestants qui prenaient des objets
pour les envoyer sur les policiers
à ce moment ils interviennent pour
neutraliser trois personnes une est au
passage et c'est le coup de matraque
était ok mais là encore moi je n'ai pas
hésité une seconde j'ai demandé au
préfet de d'engager une procédure et
qu'une enquête soit menée
mais j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'une telle
efficacité pour tous les voyous qui
viennent dans les manifestations pour
casser des commerces pour empêcher la
manifestation et pour blesser voire tuer
des policiers
on vous a entendu dire je n'ai jamais vu
un policier attaqué un manifestant ou un
journaliste est ce que vous seriez aussi
affirmatif aujourd'hui oui bien sûr que
oui parce que vous faites une vraie
différence entre des gens qui peuvent
être blessé j'ai toujours des câbles et
c'est qu'il est un gilet jaune ou
inquiet plus bleue c'est un b c'est trop
le fait que la bible est donc dans une
manifestation violente
au moment où vous avez des émeutes
urbaines la police charge
c'est sa responsabilité elle est là pour
garantir l'ordre public et d'ailleurs
elle est la seule légitime à pouvoir
utiliser la force
donc il peut y avoir des blessés mais
attention à l'amalgamé ce ne sont pas
des violences policières savez moi
j'entends encore hier à avignon
les slogans de quelques gilet jaune pas
beaucoup hein mais quelques jets les
jeunes qui sont là et qui hurle castaner
assassins les oublie peut-être les neuf
morts sur les ronds points
j'étais avignon j'ai en tête cette maman
arles qui a vu son fils mourir dans un
rond point in organisé et elle a été dit
très touché de voir ensuite j'ai déjà
récupéré la mort de son fils et des
filets avec le nom de la mort de son
fils alors même qu'ils sont responsables
il faut remettre les choses à leur place
moi je veux bien qu'ils aient le procès
permanent des forces de l'ordre mais la
réalité c'est que s'il ya des erreurs
qu'elles soient signalés et qu'elle soit
assumée par mini de l'intérieur la
madame caroline rousse ok on parle du
coup de matraque à besançon est ce que
quelqu'un un journaliste depuis trois
semaines m'a demandé des nouvelles de ce
policier qui s'est fait arracher la
mâchoire sur les champs elysées par un
pavé personne personne n'en parle vous
savez pourquoi
parce qu'on considère qu'un policier ou
un gendarme qui se fait blesser c'est
normal et on banalise cette violence là
je trouve que c'est dégueulasse je
trouve que il ya aujourd'hui des femmes
et quelques lignes on se sent vraiment
bien sûr parce que non seulement ils
sont mobilisés tous les samedis au
quotidien pour gérer l'ordre public mais
continuent à faire leur boulot hier à
avignon je les ai salue aussi pour avoir
démantelé un réseau de trafic de drogue
assez spectaculaire pour avoir enquêté
sur cinq morts parce qu'il ya eu cinq
morts sur avignon des règlements de
compte et ils ont enquêté ils ont arrêté
du monde
ils font leur travail ils peuvent faire
des fautes et les fautes doivent être
sanctionnés mais arrêtons de ne parler
que de cela parce qu'elles sont
totalement marginal vous savez dans
toutes les professions vous pourrez
faire cela mais ne jetons pas l'opprobre
sur celles et ceux qui au quotidien nous
protégera que le message est passé
christophe castaner un mot sur l'acte 21
est ce que vous redoutez une
mobilisation particulièrement forte ce
week-end non la violence forte oui mais
la mobilisation elle est faible on le
voit de semaine en semaine c'est peu de
monde qui manifestent en france et
pourtant systématiquement des tentatives
des volontés de violence à paris comme
ailleurs
et si les forces de sécurité n'étaient
pas là vous savez très bien ce qui se
passerait paris va bientôt tremblay
c'est le mot d'ordre pour pour samedi il
avait annoncé qu'il voulait brûler
avignon la semaine dernière
effectivement entre le 20 avril et le
1er mai annoncent qu'ils veulent à
nouveau faire trembler voir brûler paris
c'est ça restera identique nous
l'adaptons chaque semaine en fonction de
quoi par exemple des informations des
renseignements que nous avons parce que
il faut être mobilisés partout en france
en fonction des évolutions de ce
mouvement qui dans les manifestations
n'a toujours qu'un seul but
fuir et empêché la police de faire son
travail son travail c'est pas d'empêcher
la manifestation c'est de faire en sorte
qu'elles se déroulent bien
vous recevez vos homologues je le disais
à paris aujourd'hui et demain donc les
ministres les autres ministres des
heures dans le cadre du g7
quels sont les secteurs sur lesquels
vous considérer qu'on peut mieux faire
en matière de collaboration
est ce que c'est la lutte contre le
terrorisme est-ce que c'est la lutte
contre les contenus haineux et une forme
de terrorisme aussi on l'a vu récemment
sur sur les réseaux sociaux
dans quel secteur on peut vraiment que
faire d'abord ce sont ces deux points
j'en ai rajouté un troisième celui de la
criminalité environnementale qui est un
sujet majeur sur lequel nous devons
double
et moi ce dont je suis convaincu c'est
qu'il ya de grands sujets sur lequel
agir seul
à l'échelle de notre nation c'est au
fond accepter l'échec et donc il nous
faut nous renforcer sur les sujets que
vous avez évoquées comme la criminalité
environnementale c'est l'objet du g7 où
je réunis tous les ministres de
l'intérieur pour travailler sur cela sur
la question migratoire par exemple je
sais qu'on a des divergences de vues
avec matteo salvini avec la secrétaire
d'état américaine
on a des dégâts jans par contre il ya un
sujet qui peut nous mobiliser et qu'il
va nous mobiliser
c'est la lutte contre les passeurs c'est
ces gens qui au nom de la misère humaine
l'exploitent font beaucoup d'argent et
eu énormément de monde
eh bien on va faire cette entrée là on
va pas chercher à tomber d'accord sur
des sujets dont je sais que nous
n'aboutirons pas par contre se battre
contre les passeurs et les mettre en
prison c'est une bonne chose
merci beaucoup christophe castaing